how far along are you pregnant she's
full she's ready to go huh she's ready
to go okay all right look at me look at
me breathe through all right Mama
breathe through okay you had your water
broke you had to let me know if the
baby's coming okay is this your first
baby no how many
six oh y'all need a better hobby okay
all right just keep breathing okay I'm
not gonna move you I'm not gonna do
nothing because you feel like you look
like you're comfortable right now okay I
know it hurts but you've been through
this before okay keep breathing to it
I don't want to move her I don't want to
move no I don't want to move her only
thing I'm gonna move her straight to is
a girl and go into the ambulance okay
all right now I'm afraid if I change the
position on her the baby's gonna come
okay so I don't want to move her
very much all right you're fine
I know
don't push don't push don't push don't
push
don't push
it
I know she's pushing I know she's
pushing all right she's pushing give me
a 52.
oh it's coming
she's coming
she's coming she's coming there we go I
got a baby don't pull don't pull I got
it okay
there you go
I told you I didn't want to deliver a
baby
oh a pretty little girl